The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's go
ahead and get started again.
So we had a nice
review on Monday
of some of the
different concepts
that we've talked about up
to this point in the course.
We've covered linear
algebra, solutions of systems
of nonlinear equations.
There's been a lot of
fundamentals involved in that.
Things are going
to get more applied
as the sorts of
problems we're trying
to solve get more complicated.
Complicated problems require
very sophisticated methods
to solve them.
It's not going to be our
expectation that you're
necessarily able
to implement all
of these sophisticated methods.
So for example, you
implemented Newton's method
on your last
homework assignment.
That'll be the last time we
ask you to do that by hand.
You'll utilize tools
built into Matlab
to solve other systems of
nonlinear equations going
forward.
You understand how it works
and what the limitations are.
You understand how to
build different tools that
will be inputs to
these functions
like the function you're
trying to find the root for,
or an explicit expression
for the Jacobian.
You even understand how to set
certain parameters associated
with these methods, and what
those particular parameter
values mean.
Like setting the
function norm tolerance,
or setting the
step norm tolerance
associated with these methods.
Setting the number
of iterations you're
going to let the method go.
You've implemented
it, so you understand
what these things mean, what the
consequences of choosing them
are, how they might
increase the time associated
with computations that
you're going to conduct.
So we've done a lot
of fundamentals.
Maybe that was difficult
for some of you
who haven't seen this before.
Now things are becoming
more about the practice
of numerical methods.
How do we actually
solve things reliably,
and that's what today's
lecture will talk about.
We discussed solving systems
of nonlinear equations
and needing good initial
guesses for our methods.
Bad initial guesses can lead
to unpredictable results.
Good initial guesses, we know
the Newton-Raphson method
is going to double the number of
accurate digits each iteration,
and we should converge
very rapidly to a solution.
So it seems like having
good initial guesses is
really ideal.
And this topic, homotopy
and bifurcation,
will cover precisely
those issues,
and the practice of getting
these good initial guesses.
I think is one of the
most useful things you'll
learn in this class, actually.
It's a really nice way
of going about solving
complicated problems.
Before we begin, I want
to address a question
I got via email last night.
That's always good
if these questions
go on [? Piaza ?] so
everyone can read them,
but I thought it was a very
nice question about how
do you find-- the
question was how
do you find multiple roots
using the Newton-Raphson method.
So if I have a polynomial,
where the function
doesn't cross
through the origin,
but it just touches the
origin, and goes back up.
That's a root with
multiplicity in the polynomial.
And can the Newton-Raphson
method find that?
Because the derivative of the
function is 0 at the root.
So who says the
Newton-Raphson method will
be able to find those roots?
What do you think?
Yes?
And who says it won't be
able to find those roots?
Or who doesn't know?
You don't know.
That's OK.
That's a good question, right.
Do you know or don't you know?
So we know the
Newton-Raphson method
relies on knowing the
derivative of the function
at different points
in order to take
our next Newton-Raphson
step towards that solution.
It may be the case, the
derivative is 0 at the root,
but nearby the root, the
derivative may not be 0.
And then the Newton-Raphson
steps are going to be fine.
They're are always going to keep
stepping down towards the root.
If you go through an analysis
of how the algorithm converges,
you'll find out that you
only get linear convergence
in that case, instead of
quadratic convergence.
So there will be some
penalty to pay for the fact
that the derivative
is 0 at the root
itself, but it's not
going to be so bad.
The method can still converge
to those sorts of solutions.
Not all is lost there, but
the rate of convergence
may be not as good as
you expected it to be.
And the same is true in the
multi-dimensional case as well.
It's a little hard to imagine
what a multiple root is
going to look like.
It's something
like tangent curves
in the solution of plane.
So if I have f1 of
x1 and x2 equal 0,
that's a curve in
the x1, x2 plane.
And I have f2 in that
same plane equal to 0.
The place where they touch might
be one of these multiple roots.
That's a place where the
determinant of the Jacobian
may be equal to 0.
You'll have the same
sort of circumstance.
Nearby, the Jacobian
can be non singular,
and you can take steps
towards the root,
but there's a worst case
scenario where you're
coming in on a direction
that's parallel
that belongs to the null space
of the Jacobian at the root,
and then everything's
going to slow down.
You can still
converge, but it may
be very slow as a consequence.
I thought that was a
really nice question.
It's a detailed question about
how Newton-Raphson works.
It's not necessarily
going to fail
under these weird circumstances.
They don't come up too often.
They're going to come up in
our discussion today, actually.
It's not going to fail, but
it may converge very slowly
to the solution.
OK?
Good.
I'm going to remind
you, the last thing we
did with Newton-Raphson
methods, we
talked about one
way of fixing them.
In lieu of having
good initial guesses,
we may not want to take the
full Newton-Raphson step.
We may want to do these quasi
Newton-Raphson methods instead.
One of those was this
damp Newton-Raphson
where we introduced
some damping parameter.
We don't take the full step,
we take some shorter step,
and we try to make the
absolute value over function
become as small as possible.
That's an optimization problem.
It's as hard as finding the
root of the system of equations
that we're looking at.
So we don't solve that
optimization problem exactly.
That's crazy.
Instead we use this
backtracking line search method
where we change our
damping parameter
in some systematic way
until we get to a point
where we're satisfied.
Where we say OK, in the
process of changing this,
we've actually found a
smaller value of our function,
and we accept that
as our best guess
for where the next
iterate is supposed to go.
And this sort of
approach can give you
global convergence for the
algorithm, which is great,
but it's not globally
convergent to roots.
It's globally convergent to
minima, asymptotes, and roots
as well.
But it's globally convergent.
So it'll terminate.
The algorithm will
stop, and when it stops,
you can ask is
this a root or not?
Do I think this is sufficiently
close to a root or not?
If it's not sufficiently
close to a root,
then you know you terminated
somewhere like a minima,
or you rushed out
towards an asymptote,
and maybe you need to start
with a new initial guess
for your solution.
These quasi Newton-Raphson
methods are very useful.
This is what Matlab
uses in order to--
it uses a more
sophisticated version
of this called
the Dogleg method,
but it's the same principle.
It's trying to make
sure you're not
taking steps that are too big.
Trying to make
sure you're taking
steps in the right direction
so that you're approaching
the roots of your function.
Or at least reducing the
absolute value of your function
as close to zero
as you can get it.
Are there any
questions about this?
Anything we need to follow up
on in the previous lecture?
No.
OK, good initial guesses.
This is the key,
really, for solving
systems of nonlinear equations.
It's the key for doing
optimization problems too.
We need to have some idea of
what our solution looks like,
and we want guesses that
are close to those solutions
so that maybe we are in this
region of local convergence
for the Newton-Raphson
method, and everything
converges very quickly.
So where do they come from?
This is an important
question, and I'll
show you how you can get them.
There's another issue
too, which is related
to this, which is the
non-linear equations,
they can have multiple roots.
If we do optimization problems--
that's our next topic--
they can have multiple
minima or maxima
that we're trying to seek out.
Depending on our initial
guess, our numerical method
may find one of these
roots or another root.
It may find one of these
minima or another minima.
Maybe we're looking
for the global minimum,
so we need to look at them all.
Are there methods that we
can use to find them all?
So we'll talk about
continuation in homotopy,
and we'll talk
about bifurcation.
And it turns out
there are methods
one can use to find all
the roots for a system
of non-linear equations.
In fact, the homework
assignment you have this week
will ask you to do ternary
phase equilibrium problem.
Vapor liquid phase equilibrium
with three components.
There are five parts
to this problem.
Four of them, I think, are
relatively straightforward.
They're about finding
the pure component roots
or randomly guessing
some initial conditions
for your nonlinear
solver in order
to find all of the different
azeotropes in the system.
There's a fifth part that
asks you to actually implement
this homotopy method, and try
to find all the roots in one
go with your algorithm.
Like the other
homeworks you've had,
that part's a
little more tricky.
Usually these homeworks
have one thing
that's a little bit more
tricky than everything else.
That part is a little
bit more tricky,
but it's really instructive
to try to do it.
We'll learn how to do it today.
You can find all of the
coexisting compositions
of this ternary phase
diagram, simultaneously,
with one go through
this algorithm.
So let's talk about
continuation first.
This is an interesting
idea, and it
relates to trying to find
roots of these equations,
having good initial guesses.
Here's a simple example.
We have a third
degree polynomial,
and it has three roots.
We can look, graphically,
because this is one dimension,
and see that one of these
roots is near minus 1 and 1/2,
another root is near a 1/2,
and another root is near 1.
And so I can go to my
non-linear equation solver,
and give it initial guesses,
minus 1/2, 1/2, and 1,
and I'm probably going to find
these roots pretty reliably.
But in many dimensions,
we can't do these sorts
of graphical approaches.
You can't look at this function.
It may be difficult
to actually get
enough data to even look at it
if it's a two-dimensional set
of functions.
It's hard to see
where these roots are,
and so continuation is a method
of transforming the problem
into an easier one to solve.
So let's take this problem,
this third order polynomial,
and let's transform it.
Let's replace the 2 with
a 2 times the lambda,
and let's try to find the
roots of this polynomials
as lambda grows from 0 to 1.
This is sort of a weird
idea, but we actually
know when lambda is equal
to 0, this goes away,
and there's only one root
to this polynomial-- one
real root-- which is minus 1.
We actually know the answer
when lambda is equal to 0.
If I make lambda a
little bit bigger than 0,
there will be a root
which is close to minus 1.
In fact, minus 1 is a good
initial guess for that root,
and my non-linear
equation solver
ought to converge very
quickly to that value.
If I choose lambda
to be small, then it
should be in that region
of local convergence
of my Newton-Raphson
method, and I very quickly
should find the next root.
So I can step lambda along.
I use the lambda equals 0
root as an initial guess
for the next root, and
I keep increasing lambda
from 0 all the way up to 1,
and when lambda is equal to 1,
I'm going to find the root
to the initial problem I
was looking at.
Does that makes sense?
So I'm continuing from one
set of solutions to the next.
I vary this parameter
continuously,
and for previous values
of that parameter,
they serve as initial guesses
for the next solution.
Here's what a code that
does that would look like.
I define my lambdas.
We don't know good ways
to define the lambda.
I've got to figure
that out for myself,
but here lambda is a vector
that goes from 0 to 1,
in 1/100 increments.
Maybe that's too
fine, but that's OK.
And my initial guess for the
solution when lambda equals 0
will be minus 1, and I loop
over all the values of lambda,
and I use f0, which is the
one-dimensional non-linear
equation solver
in Matlab, to find
the roots of this
polynomial function--
x cubed minus 2 lambda x plus 1.
Here's the solution and that
becomes my initial guess
for my next solution.
So this loop is going to
go round and round until I
get lambda equals 1,
and the solution that
results there should be the
solution to the initial problem
I was interested in.
Here's what that looks
like graphically.
I started with lambda equals 0.
The root there serves as
an initial guess for lambda
equals 1/100, and so
on, and these roots
converge eventually,
to something that's
close to minus 1 and 1/2.
So the actual value is a little
bit bigger or a little bit
smaller than minus 1.6.
Here's one of the roots.
So rather than having to
have a precise initial guess,
I transformed my problem
from an easy to solve one
to a more difficult
to solve one,
and I used the path
along that transformation
to give me rapid convergence
to better and better
initial guesses to the problem
that I was interested in.
Make sense?
There's another way
of doing this too.
You don't have to
go from 0 to 1.
Let's go from lambda equals
something big back down to 1
instead.
So if lambda's big,
this term dominates
the polynomial equation.
This is the biggest term
in the polynomial equation,
and it can either balance x
cubed, or it can balance 1.
It can't balance against
both of them, it turns out.
That
So if we have this term large,
and it balances against 1, then
when lambda's large, an
approximation for the root
will be 1 over 2 lambda.
If x equals 1 over 2 lambda,
and these are the two largest
terms in the equation,
then these two will cancel,
and f will be very close to 0.
So that's one root when
lambda is very large.
If I balance these other two
terms against each other,
I'll see there are
two other roots, which
are plus or minus the
square root of 2 lambda.
So let's start with a large
lambda instead, and these
as initial guesses
for the roots--
and let's trace them
back to lambda equals 1.
When lambda equals 1,
we recover the problem
we were interested in before.
So here, I start with three
different initial guesses,
and I trace them
back, and I'm actually
able to find all three roots
of the initial equation.
So there's something
close to minus 1 and 1/2,
something close to 1/2,
and something close to 1.
So in one go, I found all
three roots using continuation.
Is this clear so far?
Sam.
STUDENT: Is that one go or is
it three separate [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: That's an
excellent question.
So I had to initiate
this process with three
separate guesses, but it
turned out in this case,
all three guesses converged
to three distinct roots
in the end.
it's one go in the
sense that there's
one trajectory that
I had to follow,
one passive lambda as
I had to go through,
but I had to solve
three times to follow
each of these three paths.
There's actually no reason
to stop at lambda equals 1.
I stopped there because that's
the solution to the problem.
I'm interested in, but there's
actually something richer
to see here.
If I keep decreasing lambda,
eventually these two branches
combine with each other,
and then they jump down,
and they follow the
original branch that I
had that went between
minus 1 at lambda equals 0,
and this root about minus
1.6 at lambda equals 1.
So the paths that these
trajectories follow
can be very, very
complicated, actually.
A little bit unwieldy
or unpredictable.
But oftentimes, they can result
in predictions of all three
roots or multiple
roots associated
with the system of equations.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Going back to the
first [INAUDIBLE] solve
from lambda equals [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Zero to one?
STUDENT: Zero to one.
So then would you find
only one solution there?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So going from 0 to 1,
I found one solution.
Going from infinity--
10 is big enough.
10 to 1, I was
able to find three.
I didn't know
beforehand that I'm
going to be able to do that.
It happened to be the
case that we could
with this by construction.
This is a particular problem
where it works out that way.
Other questions?
So this is neat.
Like we've done before
with iterative methods,
we turn hard to solve problems
into a sequence of easier
to solve problems.
Good initial guesses converge
fast with Newton-Raphson.
We have a sequence of better and
better initial guesses, which
all converge very quickly
to eventually, the solution
that we're looking for
evaluated at lambda equals 1.
So this is one way of
getting good initial guesses.
You have a sequence of
good initial guesses.
Make sense?
So we're just here.
We had this polynomial
problem and we injected lambda
in a particular place.
We injected it there because
I knew it was going to work.
I knew the problem
could be transformed
in this way in order to work
out and distinguish this.
It's not always obvious
how to transform a problem
to make it look this
way, but oftentimes we
have physical problems in
which there's a parameter
that we can do continuation
with that is obvious.
So think about fluid
mechanics problems.
Those are nonlinear partial
differential equations.
So we're trying to solve say,
the Navier-Stokes equations.
Rather than jump in and try
to solve that right away,
we might do continuation.
We might find a solution at
very small Reynolds numbers,
where the equations
are almost linear,
exact solutions are
known in that case,
and we might progressively step
the Reynolds number up, and use
our solution set small Reynolds
numbers as initial guesses
for increasingly large Reynolds
numbers until we get to the one
that we're interested in.
You can imagine doing that
in mass transfer problems
where you vary
the Peclet number.
In multicomponent phase
equilibria problems,
this might happen by
varying temperature
or pressure until we get to
the temperature or pressure
that we're interested in.
If we have reaction
equilibria problems,
we might vary the
different reaction rates
until we get to the right
balance of reaction rates
to determine the
equilibrium compositions.
So they're often natural
parameters in the problem
that we're free to adjust.
We can transform from
easy to solve problems
to hard to solve problems
in a continuous fashion.
It's not always going to work
out the way that I showed.
It's not always going
to be so nice and neat.
It may be quite a
bit more complicated,
and sometimes there
are problems for which
there isn't a natural
parameter available to vary.
In those cases, there's another
strategy one can employ.
It's called homotopy.
This is the transformation
from one problem
into another problem in
a continuous fashion.
So oftentimes, we're
seeking a set of roots.
x star, which are a function
of a parameter lambda,
and they're the roots of an
equation that looks like this.
So they're the roots
of this function, h,
which is a linear
superposition of a function
f and a function g.
When lambda equals 0, h is equal
to g, and so the roots of h
are the roots of g.
And when lambda
equals 1, h is equal
to f, and so the roots
of h are the roots of f.
So we might transform-- we
make very lambda continuously
between 0 and 1 in a
construction like this.
So we might transform the
roots from the roots of g
into the roots of f.
Maybe the roots of g are easy
to find, but the roots of f
are hard for us to find.
There's a smooth transformation
though, from g to f.
When we have those sorts
of smooth transformations,
there's a chance things
will be well-behaved,
or at least where we
encounter bad behavior--
and I'll show you what I mean
by bad behavior in a minute--
there's a reliable
way to interpret
what's going on there.
So we vary lambda in small
increments from 0 to 1,
and the solution x
star for some lambda i
is used as the
initial guess to find
the roots at some lambda,
which is a little bit bigger
than lambda i--
our next iterate in lambda.
Does this idea make sense?
Where do f and g come from?
So this is a big
question-- f is the problem
you want to solve,
typically, and g
is some auxiliary problem.
It can be arbitrarily chosen.
There's nothing to tell
you why one g should
be better than another
one, but oftentimes, we
choose them in a physical way.
So there will be a
physical connection
between the f problem
and the g problem,
and I'll show you
that right now.
So here's an example.
We looked at this
example before.
We want to find the roots
of the van der Waals
equation of state.
It's written in terms of the
reduced pressure, the reduced
molar volume, and the
reduced temperature,
and let's find those roots for a
given pressure and temperature.
So this is a function f of
the molar volume equals 0,
and we're looking for
these three roots here.
There's a root down here, which
is the molar volume is low.
Not a lot of volume per
number of moles, so maybe this
is a liquid like root.
Out here, the molar
volume is high.
We have a lot of volume, the
number of moles and materials.
This is a vapor like
root, and then there's
an unstable root
in between them.
So three roots to find.
We'd like to be able
to find them in one go,
or we'd like to have some
reliable mechanisms for finding
them.
Homotopy is one way to do this.
So let's construct a new
function h of the molar
volume, which is lambda times f.
We want to find the roots of
f plus 1 minus lambda times g.
And as g, let's use
something physical.
So let's let g be a function
that represents the ideal gas
equation of state.
So PV is nRT, but I've
written everything
in terms of the reduced
pressure, molar volume,
and temperature of the van
der Waals equation of states.
So you pick up this
factor of 8/3 there.
But this is the ideal
gas equation of state.
Its roots will be the
roots of the ideal gas
equation of states.
I'm going to transform from
something that's easy to solve.
I know how to find the molar
volume here, there's just one,
to something that's
hard for us to solve.
It has three roots--
the roots of them van der
Waals equation of state.
So when lambda equals 0,
I'll get the roots associated
with the ideal gas, and
then lambda equals 1,
I'll get the roots associated
with the van der Waals
equation.
Yes?
STUDENT: If you're
starting with lambda as 0
and you get the roots of
g, you only get one root,
but you're trying to find
two roots [INAUDIBLE]..
So how does that work?
PROFESSOR: I'll show you.
Here's what the process
might look like.
I've got to start with a reduced
temperature and pressure.
Here's my initial guess
for the molar volume.
It's the root of our
ideal gas equation.
Here's the definition of
f, and the definition of g,
and the definition of h.
l times f plus 1
minus l times g,
and I'm going to loop
over all of my lambdas,
solve the equation subject
to some initial guess,
and update my initial guess
every time I update lambda.
That's fine.
That's the code you.
Can implement the code if you
want or play around with it.
So what happens if I
try to carry this out?
So I'm going to vary
lambda between 0 and 1.
I start with my initial
ideal gas guess for the root,
and as lambda grows
to 1, the molar volume
shrinks until I get
to lambda equals 1,
and I've found one
root of my equation.
One root, good.
There's not necessarily any
reason to stop at lambda
equals 1.
That's the root I
wanted, but there's
no reason I have to stop there.
So I could continue.
If I keep pushing lambda
up higher and higher,
eventually I'll get to a
point where all of a sudden
the molar volume jumps
down to a different place.
This is the result
of the algorithm.
I just told lambda to go bigger.
But there will be a
discontinuity or a cusp
here that I jump off
of, and I find myself
on a different solution
branch, which is sort of crazy.
So now I can do
something clever.
I found myself on a
different solution branch.
Why not try decreasing lambda
along that solution branch
instead?
Maybe I'll find a
different solution,
and it turns out
that's what happens.
All right, so i jump down to
this other solution branch,
and now I try decreasing
lambda from 2 back down to 1,
and sure enough, I found
the vapor molar volume,
and now I found the
liquid molar volume.
There's no reason to
stop and lambda equals 1.
So if I keep decreasing
lambda, eventually I'll
hit another cusp,
and I'll jump back up
to the original solution branch.
So I do my homotopy.
I vary lambda from 0 to
1, and I find one root,
but if I keep going, I
might identify a cusp,
and jump off that cross.
I might reverse my
direction with the homotopy,
and I could find another root.
I might hit another
cusp as well.
Now, when I hit a
cusp, maybe it's
best not to jump off
the cusp, but instead
to reverse direction
at the cusp,
and try to trace it out
the other direction.
And if I do that, if I get
right to this last point,
and I try to reverse
direction again,
I can trace out one
more solution path,
and I can find the third
root to the equation.
So in one go, if
I'm paying attention
to how my roots are changing--
if they change by too much,
I might switch the direction
with which I change lambda,
and I could find all
of these roots at once.
So three roots in one go.
Yes.
STUDENT: Is this
like trial and error?
How do you know when to change?
PROFESSOR: This is a
wonderful question.
So in this case, you can
do it by trial and error.
You can detect these jumps.
That's even better.
You look for jumps in the
value of the solution that
are of sufficient magnitude,
and when you detect them,
you can reverse the direction.
There's an even
more systematic way
to do this, which is called
arclength continuation.
Give me one second,
and I'll give you
slide on arclength
continuation, which
is a systematic way of doing
exactly this process of tracing
out this path in
the solution plane.
Roots versus homotopy parameter.
These cusps here, are sometimes
called turning points,
and they have a
special property,
which is the determinant of
the Jacobian of the homotopy--
the homotopy function--
is going to be equal to 0.
The Jacobian is going to be
singular right at these cusps.
So you can detect
them by tracking what
the Jacobian is doing right.
The Jacobian is going to
be non-singular at most
of these other
points, but when you
hit one of these turning points,
the Jacobian will be singular.
There isn't a well-defined
direction for the homotopy
to proceed along.
It hits this cusp
where the slope
is infinite in this plane.
There isn't a well-defined
direction to step along here.
The question was--
OK, it seems a little ad-hoc.
You've got this
2D plane, and it's
easy to guess when you jump
from one solution to another,
and trace the path back.
That's fine.
There's a systematic
way of doing
this, which is called
arclength continuation, which
says I know that there's some
curve in this solution plane.
There is some curve here.
I've shown it to
you graphically.
Let's try to parametrize
that curve in terms
of a measure of the arclength.
Call it s, the distance
along the curve.
So the roots are a
function of lambda,
which can be a function of
the distance along the curve,
and lambda is a function of
and there is a
constraint which says
s has to satisfy an
arclength formula.
This is the formula for
the arclength in this plane
of roots versus lambda.
The derivative of this
function with respect to s
squared plus the derivative
of lambda with respect to s
squared equals 1.
That defines s as a measure
of length along this curve.
You learned arclength formulas
in the context of integration
at one point.
This is the differential
version of that same formula.
So I've got a
differential equation.
Well, it's actually a
differential algebraic
equation.
This is an algebraic
constraint that
needs to be satisfied
for all values of s,
and it depends on how
the roots change with s.
We'll learn how to
solve differential
algebraic equations in
the two sections from now.
So we don't quite know how to
solve something like this yet,
but if we know how to solve
those sorts of equations,
then it's clear that
we can trace out
this entire curve in
the solution plane,
and then go back and try to
find the places where the curve
intersects lambda equals 1.
So if we follow this path by
solving this equation from s
equals 0 out to
some very large s,
then we should be able to
find all of the roots that
are connected to the path.
Yes.
STUDENT: If there's a turning
point that [INAUDIBLE] then
does that imply multiplicity?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So it's a real problem.
That turning point
singularity is actually
built into this arclength
formula as well.
This is the derivative
of x with respect
to s squared, which takes
the direction you're
moving in out of the problem.
This is a length,
not a direction.
So when we get to
these turning points,
the solution methods
for these equations
are going to have to
know that I was headed
in a downward direction first.
I can get to this turning
point, and then the question
is which direction do I move
in from the turning point?
Do I go up or do I go down?
Which way does the
solution path change?
The slope isn't defined there,
so it's quite challenging
to figure out exactly
how to proceed.
But it is what you say.
It's like the solution has
multiplicity at that point.
Curves are tangent in
the solution plane.
It's a great question.
OK, so that's the notion
of arclength continuation.
We may talk about
this later when
we talk about differential
algebraic equations,
and we'll talk about some
equivalent sets of equations
that we know how
to solve, but they
have to satisfy this
constraint that s
is a measure of arclength
along the curve.
But there you go.
You can find all the solutions,
at least all of the solutions
connected to this path defined
by the homotopy equation.
You can find all of
them in one go using
some clever methodologies.
Oftentimes, we're not
just worried about these
turning points or cusps,
we encounter bifurcations
in the solution.
So we may have a path that
has one root along it,
and then that path
may split, and there
may be more than one root.
Here's a simple example.
Find the real roots
of x cubed minus rx.
If r is negative, there will
always be one real root,
and it'll be x equals 0.
If r is equal to 0, there will
still be one real root, it's 0.
That root will have
multiplicity 3 in that case.
And if r becomes
positive, I'll suddenly
have three real
roots instead of one.
So as I vary the parameter
r from a negative number
to a positive number, I'll go
from one real root to three.
In the solution plane,
that will look like this.
Here are the roots
as a function of r.
r is less than 0.
All the roots are equal to 0.
When I hit r equals
0, I have multiplicity
associated with the root,
and the solution bifurcates,
and there will be three
possible solutions now.
If I was trying to do a
homotopy problem where I very r
continuously from some negative
number to some positive number,
I'll hit this
point, and I'll want
to follow all three paths
to find solutions out here
at positive r.
But I can detect those points.
Just like I was said before,
at these weird turning points
or bifurcations where we have
multiplicity in the roots,
the Jacobian in is
going to be singular.
The Jacobian of the homotopy
is going to be singular.
Its determinant
will be equal to 0.
So I can detect these points
by checking the determinant
of the Jacobian.
And when I find
one, I want to do
something smart to try
to follow these paths.
Your homework this week
has a problem like that.
You're trying to find all the
azeotropes of this ternary
vapor liquid equilibrium
system, and you'll
have a homotopy parameter
that you change,
and it'll bifurcate.
OK, so as you change
the parameter,
you'll go from one path to
two, and then those two paths
will split again.
You'll be splitting from a
single component solution
into a two component azeotrope,
into a three component
azeotrope.
And you'll want to detect
where these bifurcations occur,
and try to follow
solution branches off
of those bifurcations,
and there's
some good hints in the
problem for how to do that.
So occasionally, we'll
encounter problems
that switch from having
one solution to having
many solutions.
You've seen how this happens
in the discontinuous sense
with these turning points.
Here, for a given
value of lambda,
all of a sudden it's clear that
not only is there one solution
here, but there's another
solution down there.
My path has to choose.
Do I want this solution
or the one below?
I jump off this turning point.
That's a sort of bifurcation.
These are continuous
bifurcations.
They're often easier
to take care of.
So the bifurcations
in a homotopy
let us find multiple solutions.
Every time we detect
a bifurcation,
if we just track those
solution branches,
we split our algorithm up to
track each of the branches
separately, they'll
terminate at different roots
to the homotopy equation.
And when we get to the
value of lambda equals 1
in our homotopy, we're there.
We found multiple roots
to the original equation.
These are often of
great physical interest.
Do you know what sort of things
these bifurcations represent?
One occurs in the van
der Waals equation.
So if I start at very high
temperatures and a given
pressure, the van
der Waals equation
will have how many real roots?
One-- a gas.
And then as I turn
the temperature down,
there is a propensity for
liquefaction of that gas phase.
The formation of a liquid in
coexistence with the vapor.
So I'll go from having one
root to having three roots
all of a sudden, and there
will be this bifurcation
point where that
transition happens
in a continuous fashion.
STUDENT: Can I ask
you a question?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
STUDENT: So as you early put
it out that the turning point,
the determinant of the Jacobian
[INAUDIBLE] including lambda
is singular.
But here you're writing j of x.
Is that [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Excuse me.
This is a typo.
So there should be
a little h here.
This is the determinant
of the Jacobian
of the homotopy
equation at that root.
Where there's a bifurcation,
the Jacobian will be singular.
I apologize.
That's a little bit--
STUDENT: And that lambda.
PROFESSOR: And that lambda.
STUDENT: Just to make it clear,
you have n state variables.
Like x is how many
unknowns you have,
and then you're adding
another unknown to lambda,
another parameter.
This Jacobian has
n plus 1 dimension.
This is also [INAUDIBLE]
Is this correct?
PROFESSOR: Well, no.
Actually, the Jacobian
with respect to x only
is also singular at these
turning and bifurcation points.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] as well.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
It's also true what you said,
that if I have the Jacobian,
and I take the
derivatives with respect
to lambda, that will
also be singular,
but it will be singular
because the subspace, which
is the derivatives
with respect to x,
gives you a singular component.
The condition is
the same as here.
So it's the Jacobian of
h, taking the derivatives
with respect to x--
all the different x's of h.
The determinant of that
matrix at a particular lambda
will be equal to 0,
and the value of lambda
will be the lambda at which
you have this turning point,
or which you have a bifurcation.
Here's what it looks like
in a two-dimensional sense.
So I'll have my
homotopy equation
where I'm trying to
find the roots of h.
Say it's a two-dimensional--
x is dimensions.
So it has x1 and
x2, and these curves
represent h1 equals
0 and h2 equals 0,
and they intersect at one point
for a given value of lambda.
There's the root.
Now I increase the
value of lambda.
The homotopy equations change.
So these curves change
shape, and all of a sudden I
go from crossing curves
to tangent curves,
and we know tangent
curves in the plane
will have a Jacobian
which is singular.
And this is the
bifurcation point.
These two curves become
tangent, and as I
go to a bigger value of lambda,
they'll change shape again,
and I'll now have
multiple roots.
I'll bifurcate from
one solution to two,
or one solution to three,
but the bifurcation
will occur through
this transition
where I have tangent
curves, and we know there,
the determinant of
the Jacobian is 0.
There's a singularity
under those conditions.
Does that makes sense?
OK, so a couple of things
about the practice, and I'll
give you a simple example you
can try out, which I think
is an interesting
one, if pathological.
So in practice, it's hard to hit
this bifurcation point exactly.
And I'm telling
you that you should
be detecting these branches.
You should follow
these branches,
but clearly, I've got to know
where this point is in order
to follow the branches.
That's a problem.
If the determinant
of the Jacobian
is 0 at the bifurcation
point, then it's
going to change from
positive to negative as I
cross the bifurcation
point with lambda.
Actually, I don't
necessarily have
to find the point where the
determinant of the Jacobian
is equal to 0.
What I really should
do is try to track
the sign of the determinant
of the Jacobian,
and see when it
goes from positive
signed to negative signed.
And when it does
that, it will have
crossed through one of
these bifurcation points
or one of these cusps.
That's the point at
which I should stop,
and say, OK, there's possibly
other solution branches
to follow.
So as I step from my smaller
lambda to my bigger lambda,
the sign changes.
I want to step in some
different directions
than the direction I
was heading before,
and those different
directions will trace out
the other solution branches.
It turns out those
different directions
belong to the null
space of the Jacobian.
So if you find
vectors that are very
close to the null
space of the Jacobian,
those directions
are the directions
you should go to find these
other solution branches.
So it's very interesting.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Can you have a Jacobian
that goes from positive down
to 0 and [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That may be possible.
You won't encounter that in
the problem that you're doing.
That would be a very
difficult problem
to do branch detection on.
Let's Suppose that
was the case and you
want to find exactly where
that bifurcation point is.
These bifurcation points are
of physical significance.
In the van der Waals
equation of state,
that bifurcation point
is the critical point.
It's the critical temperature
at which that phase separates.
Maybe I want to
know that exactly.
Well, all I need to do is
solve an augmented system
of equations.
So let's solve a
system of equations,
which is our original
hematology equation equal to 0,
and determinant of the Jacobian
of this homotopy equation
equal to 0.
This is if h had dimension n.
This is now n plus 1
equations, and let's
solve it for n plus 1 unknowns.
Let's solve it for x and for
lambda. x has dimension n,
and we add one more unknown--
the value of the homotopy
parameter at which
this bifurcation occurred.
So we can find
that point exactly.
So there may be cases
where this happens
where it doesn't
continuously transition
from positive to negative.
It may hit 0 and go
back up, but that's
a really challenging case to
handle, but you can handle it.
You can find precisely
the point at which
this bifurcation
occurs by solving
these augmented equations.
It's just another non-linear
equation to solve.
Yes.
STUDENT: I'm not sure
about the previous slide.
So in the previous slide,
why is the [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Let me
go back to here.
So let's let the
blue line here, be
the place where the first
element of h is equal to 0.
So this is all the
values of x at which
the first element of our
homotopy top equation
is equal to 0.
And the red curve
here, let's let
that be all the values of x at
which the second element of h
is equal to 0.
And so h itself, is only equal
in 0 where both of these curves
are equal to 0, and
that's their intersection.
So they intersect here, and
this star is the solution.
It is the root of this
non-linear equation up here.
Now, I increase lambda.
I make lambda a
little bit bigger.
That changes h.
h is a function of lambda.
So h changes, and these curves
change shape in the plane.
And at that bifurcation
point, these two curves
will become tangent
to each other.
There will be one root,
but in this solution plane,
the two curves will be tangent.
And we saw before
that when we get
these sort of
tangency conditions
or the equivalent in
higher dimensions,
the Jacobian of
our function we're
trying to find the roots
of will be singular.
It's like a multiple root.
And when we increase
lambda further,
curves change shape again.
I'm not changing the red one
because that's complicated.
I just changed the
blue one for you
as a graphical illustration.
So the blue one changes
shape, and now I've
gone from having one
solution to having three.
So in order to go from
one solution to three,
in a continuous
fashion, I have to go
through this tangency state,
and that defines the bifurcation
point.
Does that make sense?
Here's a simple example
you should try out.
So I'll present it
to you, and then you
should try to
solve it in Matlab.
You actually know the
solution, geometrically,
so it's not too hard.
So here's a function.
The first element
to that function,
it's a function of two
unknowns-- x1 and x2.
The first element
to that function
is an equation for a circle of
radius r with center at minus 3
minus 1, and the
second element is
an equation for a circle of
radius r with center at 2, 2.
So there's two circles.
We want to find the radius
where the circles just touch,
and that point is a
bifurcation point.
If r is perfect,
these two just touch.
If r is a little too big,
the two circles overlap,
and there are two
solutions to this problem.
And if r is a little
too small, there
are no solutions
to this problem.
So the perfect r for touching
is a bifurcation point.
It has all the properties
of a bifurcation point,
just like we discussed.
It's a multidimensional
equation and it bifurcates.
You know the solution to
this problem, geometrically.
You could work it out
in a couple of minutes,
but you could also
solve it using
these augmented equations.
So we know that point at
which the circles just touch,
the value of r at which
those circles just touch,
will be the place where
f of x is equal to 0
at which these equations
define a circle,
and at which the Jacobian
of these equations--
the derivatives of f with
respect to x, it's determinant
is also equal to 0.
So we want to solve this system
of three equations for three
unknowns.
The values of x1 and x2,
where the circles just touch,
and the value of r, the
radius of these circles
at which they just touch.
That would find the
bifurcation point.
That will find the
touching of the circles.
Can you see that, geometrically?
All these bifurcation problems
work exactly that way.
There's some homotopy parameter.
In this case, that's r.
But there's some parameter
we're varying as we
pass through that bifurcation.
We'd like to know the
values of our unknowns
and the value of this parameter
at that bifurcation point
or at that critical point.
So you find this
point by solving
the augmented equations.
We have a non-linear equation--
three nonlinear equations
for three unknowns,
and you can do
that with a
Newton-Raphson iteration.
It's a non-linear equation.
We know Newton-Raphson is the
way to solve these things.
To do Newton-Raphson, that
means we need to compute
the Jacobian--
this is confusing.
We've got to
compute the Jacobian
of these augmented
equations, the derivatives
equations with respect
to our augmented unknowns.
So that will be the
derivatives of f with respect
to x, the derivatives
of f with respect
to r, the derivatives of the
determinant of the Jacobian
with respect to x.
That's this gradient here.
The derivatives of the
determinant of the Jacobian
with respect to r.
This is our augmented Jacobian.
The augmented Jacobian times
the Newton-Raphson step.
That's equal to
minus the function
we're trying to solve evaluated
at the previous iteration.
Solve the system of
equations, you'll
get your Newton-Raphson step,
and you can find the solution
to the augmented equations.
It'll converge quadratically.
You should commit yourself,
you can figure this out.
Don't try to compute all
of these derivatives.
That's complicated.
You're going to make a mistake.
I'm going to make a mistake
if I try to do that.
What do we do instead
to compute the Jacobian?
How do we compute
these derivatives?
What's that?
Finite difference, right.
Don't play games with it.
Try to use finite difference
to compute the elements of this
instead.
You know the exact
solution too, so you
can use that as
an initial guess,
or something close to the exact
solution as an initial guess
to see if you can find
this bifurcation point.
So homotopy
bifurcation, there are
ways to get good initial
guesses by continuously
changing our problem.
We get a succession
of problems that
will converge faster because
we have good initial guesses,
and that will give us a reliable
convergence, hopefully, to one
of the roots of the
equation we're after.
If we're able to pick up
solution branches, we can track
these cusps, or find
these bifurcation points,
we might be able to
find multiple solutions.
There are problems
for which depending
on your choice of g in
this homotopy function,
maybe some of the
solution branches
are disconnected
from each other.
Boy, that's crazy
and complicated.
We're not going to worry
about those sorts of cases,
but they can pop up and happen.
But the point is there
are a robust strategies
you can employ to
find multiple roots
of these equations or multiple
minima in optimization problems
using precisely this technique.
You'll have a chance to practice
this on this week's homework
assignment, and I
think you should
take a look at this problem.
It's simple.
It looks complicated , but if
you can understand this from,
then you'll understand
everything you need to know
about bifurcation and homotopy.
Any questions?
Yes.
STUDENT: At a
bifurcated point, we
go from having one root
to three roots, per se.
And you said that
when that occurs,
we need to follow each of
these solutions, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
STUDENT: And you said
that we need to step
in a different direction.
So what does that exactly mean?
In a 2D sense, we have
this stepping forward
or stepping backwards.
PROFESSOR: This is a
wonderful question.
So let me go backwards here.
Here's the bifurcation
point, and when
we go through that
bifurcation point,
there are now going
to be three solutions.
And I'm going to need
some initial conditions
for my solver to find each
of these three solutions.
I can't give them all the
same initial condition.
I'm going to try to track
all three of these branches
with different
initial conditions.
If I give them all the
same initial condition,
and my algorithm meets the
minimum threshold for what
an algorithm should
be, they're all
going to converge
to the same root.
So that's useless.
So I need to give them
different initial conditions.
So what are those
supposed to be?
In your problem, I'll give
you explicit directions
for how to find those.
It turns out those
initial guesses
should be perturbed
in directions
that belong to the null
space of the Jacobian.
So I want to perturb from that
one solution, which was here,
in a direction that's
parallel to the tangency
of those curves.
Those two curves were
tangent with each other.
In the other solutions,
they're going
to sit off in the direction
that's tangent to those curves.
So I've got to find the vector
that's in the null space,
or very, very close
to the null space,
and that will tell me how to
get better initial guesses
for picking up these
other solution branches.
It's not trivial.
It's actually quite challenging.
You'll have a
chance to practice.
It's part five of five
parts on this problem.
The first four,
they're relatively
straightforward and easy.
Part five is a
little bit tricky.
You get explicit
directions, and the TAs
know that that's the most
difficult part of that problem.
So we'll help you through it.
It's something interesting
to think about trying to do.
You may find you're only able to
pick up some of these solution
branches, but not all of them.
That's OK.
There are ways to pick them
all up if your algorithm is
designed well enough.
You may just pick
up some of them,
and that may be the
result you turn in.
You can look at the
solution to figure out
how the other ones
are picked up as well.
But you're looking
at the direction
along these tangent curves.
That's a vector in the
null space of the Jacobian.
And if you perturb
in those directions,
then you can trace
out these other roots
so you can find the bifurcation.
It's a wonderful question.
You'll get a chance
to practice on it.
OK, last question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
STUDENT: Is this
supposed to be jrx?
PROFESSOR: That's
the Jacobian of f.
That's the derivatives
of f with respect to x.
STUDENT: Not including r?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Not including derivatives
with respect to r.
Just derivatives
with respect to x.
So this is the Jacobian of f.
The derivatives of
f with respect to x.
The determinant of that will
be 0 at the bifurcation point.
It'll turn out that--
this will be the
last thing and then
I have to get off
the stage here.
It'll turn out that this
matrix is also singular
at the bifurcation point.
It will be singular because
the subspace j is singular.
So it'll turn out to
be singular as well.
Don't worry about it.
The condition for
the bifurcation point
is that the determine of
the Jacobian is equal to 0,
and that point is a root of the
equations you're looking at.
OK, thank you.